how do you create a horror protagonist
how do you create our protagonist again
I would say the same way you create any
other protagonist which means your goal
is to have the audience build a
relationship with that person that they
are not ambivalent about him or her
they can hate her or love him or
whatever but there has to be some kind
of emotional connection because
otherwise none of the horror set pieces
that follow will mean anything because
it happens to a person we don't care
about so we need the audience needs to
care you know and then the question is
how do you achieve that there is the
whole save the cat kind of concept that
you have to have that one moment where
the protagonist displays some kind of
humanity where I see myself I recognize
myself and that person or I you know I
kind of want that person to be okay and
like that person there's humor which is
a great weapon I think to make the
audience kind of identify with a person
but it's hard and it's very rarely done
like if I have to if I'd have to tell
you horror protagonists right now where
that is the case I'd have difficulties
with that you know and then you see the
script I just read it script by a friend
of mine for for a pilot where she
achieves that in the first two pages
which in that case was very simple if
you look at it if someone has done it
and done it well it's so it's so simple
it's basically a girl in a college
environment who is doing and has big
stage fright and is going to their
talent show they're open mic thing to do
a political art thing and you love her
so much I think because you can identify
with that fear to go up in front of
everybody but she does it anyway because
of her conviction because she cares so
much and she cares about bees in that
case she's the torment of the bees is
something that she just has to tell her
to the world because she can't bear how
bees
treated so that combination of someone
will look social death strated the I to
save bees I was like that girl I'm on
board with as a protagonist
even if she on page three starts killing
people I would still go like you go girl
you know and that's a huge huge go and
that's I think not at all
genre dependent that's a very
interesting question if you ask our
other horror film makers if they have an
angle on how they establish their
protagonists that is influenced by the
fact that they're working in horror I
know that that's not the case to me for
sure I think what Jamie Lee Curtis his
character it seemed like she was pretty
much well-liked through through you know
it in Halloween
that's definitely was the darling
they'll be interesting to dissect why
that was the case like why do people
gravitate to some characters because I
there I couldn't tell you it kind of
saved the cat moment for example when
she was established necessarily which
are other horror protagonists that you
feel strongly about that they have a
strong sympathy for well Carey
I always felt Carey but I don't think I
think Carey was more polarizing because
people thought she was creepy so she
quote deserved it right I think
unfortunately that's a mob mentality but
that is okay too because it's an emotion
and an investment that that half of the
audience hates Carey and the other half
loves Carrie that is goal achieved you
know you don't need one hundred percent
of the audience to lover you just want
to keep the number of people that are
indifferent towards your protagonist as
low as possible you know and Carey is a
great example where I think that was
very very successfully done for sure
right right and um Linda Blair I think
she was more more liked you know she was
sort of she wasn't her fault that she
was possessed but then didn't open air
and The Exorcist is is like a type if
you had to tell me what that girl was
really like I don't think it's a very
interesting personality where you got
like oh that she came so true life
as a human being that I can't get her
out of my head like you could have
that's the stuff that happened to her
was so horrendous that if you had that
happen to any child they would probably
have that effect you know I don't even
know if the act or if even the shining
if I go through there there are not many
there not many movies that successfully
do that period but I think there
probably even less in in horror if I had
to speculate I would say that has to do
with a misguided focus on horror set
pieces that we think a good horror movie
is made of great horror set pieces which
is true but that the character
development is overlooked and that if I
if I had gone look at the sixth sense
for example that boy and his torment to
me worked so well if that if there had
been no ghosts and it was just about
that boy I would still care about that
boy because he was you what they were so
well act it was so well directed it was
so well written that I cared by the time
that the scary stuff started happening
or just a stick with Shyamalan an
unbreakable I know has this one moment
in the very beginning where the boy was
yearning to spend time with his father
the father is calling him and he's on a
playground playing soccer with his
friends and he goes like guys guys I
gotta go I have to hang out with my
father and then he turns around again it
goes I'm gonna spend time with my dad it
was so I could cry right now it was so
heartbreaking it was so beautiful and
just from those two lines I care you
know and was that even the question what
was the question
holy well how do you make a great horror
protagonist right mm-hmm yes yeah just
make me ideally make me fall in love
with a character and I think that's much
like in real life sometimes one moment
makes you fall in love with someone and
garlic I care about that person because
I've seen a vulnerability or whatever it
is that that moment it if you can create
that with your protagonist that's a huge
achievement that will pay off usually
throughout your movie right and even
when they have ugly moments because
everybody does you could see someone in
one moment and they're having the worst
day possible and then
you're gonna brand that person as a
horrible human being every time you see
them because that was your first right
but with the movie yeah we get a chance
to see a better would build up yeah you
see that in documentaries about serial
killers they always show that picture of
the serial killer as a child done you
know Jessica like no that's the starting
point that innocence and then something
happened to them that made them into
this monster but it's such a such an
easy trick to just do that but it works
for everybody because it's this cute
child that deserve better than to be
turned into a serial killer you know
that's a great analogy yes that
mechanism I thank you right right and so
then yeah you see that that photo and
then you hear sort of you know the hard
life or whatever that went with it and
so then you softened toward the person
everything that happens after that you
link back to that yeah even though they
had like seven bodies buried in the
backyard but they you saw and see a
little child and then ya think how could
they yeah
Eileen warned us I think it's a great
document yeah making of a serial killer
I was just thinking about her I was
thinking what you talked about I was
like she's talking about eliwood because
they did that they had this great
picture of her and then they that came
along with she had to sleep out in the
car in the snow and people bro it
doesn't matter what she does after that
you know she killed seven people I don't
care and with her you know it's it's her
tragedy that I'm watching from then on
out and it's really just it takes less
than twenty seconds to do it and it's
such a big payoff and that's what's so
crazy to me that most movies that I
watch do either not invest those 20
seconds or haven't found a good way to
make me care about the protagonist
before they take me on this journey or
Ted Bundy who was charming incredibly
bright had a high emotional IQ didn't he
act as his own attorney in court yeah
just so it's he's more forgivable
somehow is that is that it I don't know
to me Bundy is because of those things
more fascinating but it doesn't make him
any less of a monster the part that when
I read about it was that he worked for a
suicide hotline and saved people's lives
and then he turned to a serial killer so
that part
suicide hotline where he genuinely saved
people's lives on the phone now I care
all the other stuff that he was
brilliant and he represented himself in
court that is all still psychopath stuff
that is interesting it makes him such a
such an evergreen as a serial killer I
could watch Bambi stuff day and night
I'm obsessed with that man but I still
wouldn't care for him as much as I care
for Aileen Wuornos
after that childhood picture if I hadn't
heard that piece about the the suicide
hotline you know where's John Wayne Gacy
maybe you know yeah I think you know the
whole the the the the physical I I hate
to go there but are we blinded by that
in terms of our our our protagonists and
antagonists and the whole clown thing
and it was great you know
whereas Bundy you probably put a
modern-day one many women would have
fallen for it it did be very easy and
then maybe that's what makes it even
more terrifying you see someone a
certain way you think okay yeah that
could be that quote serial killer
composite right what's someone like you
know could never no way well it's always
so crazy to me that when when you hear
people tell their stories you are on
their side with all crime shows always
happen there's this meek person let's
say BTK the BTK killer this meek person
in court that says yes sir sorry sir oh
yes sir and you can't help but liking
him and you know that he has like hung
children from the ceiling and let them
suffocate and then you know crazy stuff
like you can't bring those two things
together I had that with a friend of
mine got murdered in Germany and yeah in
film school and I went to the trial and
saw the person that shot him
and I could not bring myself to hate
that guy even though I should have
because he was telling his story from
his point of view you know and I just
couldn't put those two things together
and I think that is maybe a lesson in
storytelling but it's all about point of
view and about the angle and what you
spend time on obviously in that case
they suddenly spent a lot of time on its
try
hood work before that I was only
spending time like my energy on the
moment of my friend getting murdered but
it depends on where you start that story
and how much emphasis you put on stuff
and maybe got to bring that back to
horror movies a lot of horror movies
seem to not look not spend a lot of time
on that character development but rush
to the first set piece as quickly as
possible and you always have the opening
sequence for this family with the boxes
are standing in front of the old spooky
house if they just inherited or whatever
we were like really err but I think they
would be they would be better served
spending more time on that energy which
again doesn't have to be much time even
but to to hammer home that moment but I
can put my finger on in the script and
got like this is the moment that is
going to make my audience fall in love
with my protagonist that should almost
be a requirement for every scene show me
that moment and you almost shouldn't
read on if you can't put your finger on
that moment because you know that
something is wrong with with that script
that sounds harsh but I think we would
get much better movies if that were a
requirement for the writer to point out
that the point where he or she thinks
the audience will fall enough for the
project or hate the programs or develop
some emotional attachment to the
protagonist
you